remember Sarah Palin that kooky chick
from Alaska well she wrote a piece on
breitbart.com yesterday that's where I
get all my news and basically calling
for the impeachment of President Obama
we've got a little snippet for you
President Obama's rewarding of
lawlessness including his own is the
foundational problem here it's not going
to get better and in fact irreparable
harm can be done in this lame-duck term
as he continues to make up his own laws
as he goes along and mark my words will
next metal in the US Court system with
appointments that will forever change
the basic interpretation of US
Constitution's roles in protecting our
rights okay so she's talking about a lot
of things if you read the whole article
and we'll link to it below she's talking
about some of the immigration stuff
she's talking about sort of selecting
the Obama care laws that he's going to
enforce and a whole slew of other things
in court appointments and executive
actions etc etc so before we get to the
specifics should anyone on earth pay any
attention to what Miss Sarah Palin is
saying no but I mean but she clearly she
has a form then you know when I was
reading this piece on Breitbart talk
comfortable to even open that web let
the virus yes can you imagine if one of
your you know Hollywood friends had seen
use like looking over the she's a
cartoon I mean she's a cartoon to us but
we have to remember yeah that there are
people who heed her words and that's
that's the staggering thing really yeah
you know the cheek she does hold weight
how much weight do you think she
actually holds because I do agree with
that we can make fun of her but
obviously there is some percentage that
really digs this woman I think that
she's still an important figure for a
lot of Americans and I mean clearly
we're talking about her and she's got
this forum on wherever she wants to
write a piece like that she can she
could have written it on the Huffington
Post I'm sure they would have published
it as well and so I mean it's just it's
it's scary you know she talks about that
she's afraid that Obama's gonna meddle
in the US courts I hope he mentally
please know it is already being
obliterated for the scene last week with
with that Hobby Lobby you know decision
the horse has left the barn on that one
yeah so all he oh huh Obama can do I
think but of course people who labeled
me as a crazy liberal well I think that
he can do is start to repair it yeah and
of course both sides only care about
activist judges when they do things that
they don't like nobody really seems to
have any principle or consistency when
they're doing well than I do like right
then somehow that's out the window why
why can't we get rid of her though so I
get if there's a certain amount of
people that like her but why does she
like I just heard this week she may host
the view like she may be the next name
they lost Sherri and what's her name
McCarthy and now they're not gonna hire
no GU it I think she would probably
should if she's a [ __ ] I mean she is I
mean John's not not a [ __ ] [ __ ] but
she's a media [ __ ] she's a media will
do anything so do you think what do you
tell me I can use language that's one of
the benefits of being the third time
guest you're allowed to start very
nearly I wasn't allowed to before the
first two you were not allowed I just
think that when we're when she's out
there talking about immigration it's
hard to take anybody from Alaska
seriously when they're attacking on
immigration like if Rick Perry want me
talking about immigration at least you
go yeah will you understand some of the
flex is I'm sure in Texas but she's like
what where the Russians are immigrating
into Alaska it's like well you can still
longer I mean you can be a person who
lives anywhere and understand them they
I mean I'm sorry I can't use I think
these are Perry's or anything for the
record that's the first time anyone has
ever said anything nice about Rick Perry
yeah they were gonna meet on the tarmac
and he refused to do it he wanted to
take a private meeting and then Obama
didn't wanna do that so they but he
still walked out to the tarmac to see
what are you doing
anyway we don't want to get off your
okay so do you think any of these things
like the executive and we've talked a
lot about the executive actions on the
show that they're giving him no choice
because they won't the Congress won't
give him laws so they give him no choice
but again I still do believe in
separation of power so I think both
sides are being sort of disingenuous
here or something is there any of this
that you don't like that he's doing any
of this stuff the executive actions any
of it okay personally I really think
he's over a barrel here I mean I really
don't think they've give me any wiggle
room they don't work with him yeah so
what's he supposed to do so you don't
mind the executive action things which
we both talked about how he did he's now
or less than even Georgia honest if he
were not someone whose actions and views
I agreed with I probably would take
offense you know I have to be honest
right that but in my case here when
we're dealing with a Congress that is
ridiculous and completely just blocks
any kind of move to make progress what
is he supposed to do yeah I'm glad you
said that because that's what I've been
saying every week that whether I believe
in if it was the other guy if it was a
Republican taking all these executive
actions people would be going crazy
yeah MSNBC would be going nuts so we
still have to be aware yeah although it
is less than you know that presidents
before but I mean yeah for me Obama
could have could have fought harder to
protect the environment and and and
regulations I know that he was up over a
barrel with it but that's been
disappointing about a majority for a
certain amount of time yak-9 months or
something like that
final thought on this isn't it in
retrospect now crazy to think that Bill
Clinton was impeached or almost
impeachment was he technically impeached
it was in place but not yeah she went
through like in retrospect isn't that
crazy considering it was really about a
[ __ ] and the word is yeah like no it
was it was it was embarrassing which it
was it was stupid it was stupid and and
the way I mean I'm not that I don't
really care what you know other people
think of us yeah but the way we look to
the world i salient that yeah my god
don't we wouldn't it be nice if we look
that way in the world again like America
getting their [ __ ] like that it
seems like the good old days to me right
compared to everything they think of us
now right the nineties the last great
decade don't they sir I mean really well
I shouldn't get a t-shirt really and it
just says not my president you know as
far as like Bush you know well not now
she's saying exactly yeah I do we do a
lot of there's a lot of space a lot of
things that I would have to do that
probably would move forward on but which
are difficult but you know when he was
around and people were complaining I
really was like this is not home this is
not who I wanted this is if he does not
represent Bush yeah he does not
represent me yeah and but you know then
again a lot of idiots I'll call them
idiots cuz I think they are will say the
same thing about Obama that they he
doesn't represent them yeah well I guess
that's why we vote and half the people
hate the guy no matter what so they're
yeah yeah